[Music]
MGM Resorts International responding
tonight after two-thirds of hotels on
the Las Vegas Strip have been named in a
class action lawsuit accused of
illegally fixing room rates in an
attempt to gouge customers that lawsuit
filed in District Court this week by a
Seattle Law Firm it argues companies
including MGM Resorts Caesar's
entertainment wind Resorts and Treasure
Island among others are artificially
inflating hotel room prices and
overcharging guests the lawsuit claims
those companies used a revenue platform
called ring maker to monitor real-time
prices for their competitors so an
algorithm could adjust their rates on
the fly to maximize profits we did reach
out to numerous casinos for a response
MGM Resorts International responded by
saying quote the claims against MGM
Resorts are factually inaccurate and we
intend to defend ourselves vigorously
against these meritless claims you can
read more about this lawsuit on our
website 8newsnow.com